as we approach Election Day here's one
thing that has become patently obvious
Democrats are uninterested in the things
Americans care about most their
prosperity and their safety instead of
policy prescriptions Democrats poison
American discourse with constant
demonization and perpetual intimidation
and in the Cavanagh saga we saw that
they're masters at producing coordinated
choreographed outrage after that
backfire Democrats began to panic
although still favored to take the House
of Representatives things began to shift
somewhat after the Kavanagh does settled
stories suddenly begin to pop up that
Pelosi and Schumer and company were
concerned that Latino voters weren't
sufficiently enthusiastic in the
midterms which of course could doom
Democrat chances to take the house then
like magic a few days later a story
appeared out of nowhere about another
caravan of Central Americans headed to
the u.s. from Honduras
in it how's he been doing Aki working
like yahoo a former Honduran left-wing
politician even joined the caravan for a
time before he was arrested so what
started as a group of 1,600 soon became
2000 and then four thousand and
apparently growing meanwhile crusading
reporters are feeding the narrative that
anyone opposed to welcoming these
caravanners into our country are cruel
horrible awful rotten people so what is
the GOP strategy we see it at this point
as to push fear and loathing if you
don't vote this scary people from the
South are coming for you you see that
picture that's what they want you to
think all immigrants look like people
laying on the floor splayed out not as
civilized as you different from you
the media is over-the-top slurs against
those of us who believe that the system
must change and that our border has to
be protected it speaks volumes about
their bias and their real motivation of
course which is to help Democrats like
presidential hopeful Julian Castro the
president continues to fear monger
around the issue of immigration one of
the worst things that's happened in
these last 18 months has been the
basically state-sponsored
state-sponsored child abuse of young
kids at the border this example today of
what he says is a caravan
you know he's picking that and he's
trying to make an issue of it to gin up
his base I think that the American
people can see through that you know
what the American people see through
Democrats phony compassion politically
timed in a desperate attempt to turn out
Latino voters who themselves are seeing
the wonders of the Trump economy record
low unemployment and the best economy in
decades now Castro was mayor of San
Antonio and his twin brother Joaquin he
represents San Antonio in Congress but
I've never seen either of them on
television standing for the families of
those brood
we murdered by illegal aliens brutally
brutally hurt by rape spousal abuse
child abuse and as I said even murder
today crime scene tape boarded up doors
and broken glass are still outside this
apartment on Jones multirow Road it was
here just yesterday where firefighters
found a badly burned body
police arrested and charged 20-year old
Ernesto Esquivel Garcia with murder
arson and abuse of a corpse news for San
Antonio has learned US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement is now a part of
this investigation now ice was
apparently involved from the very
beginning and this story even before the
gruesome murder now back in 2017 Garcia
was arrested for a DWI and a misdemeanor
criminal mischief after he reportedly
rammed his truck into the cars of an
ex-girlfriend and her family members he
got an immigration judge though to give
him a voluntary departure order now
would you be surprised to hear that he
didn't leave the country voluntarily
after that order a few months later he
was in ice custody a second time and a
second time he was given a voluntary
departure order and now in just 11 days
he awaits his trial for the murder of
jared vargas in why aren't any of the
Democrats who rail against family
separations also railing about stories
like this 55 illegal immigrants found
stuffed in a truck ready to be shipped
across the United States undoubtedly
many too unscrupulous employers our open
borders as well as our immigration and
Asylum loopholes are enriching the
cartels they're endangering migrants and
they're also making life worse for most
Americans beyond the super-rich who live
in a protected bubble so how can we
allow this to continue and still be a
country now of course not all illegal
immigrants commit violent crime and many
are good and hard-working people but
that's not really the point no American
should suffer or be brutalized in order
to fulfill the Democrats fantasy of a
borderless
no American worker should see his or her
wages go down because there's an illegal
immigrant who just arrived in the US
who's willing to work for 40 percent
less in Donald Trump
we finally have a president who wants to
tackle this problem not just pass it on
to the next president the way Obama did
and don't buy for a moment what the left
is selling you Democrats are the ones
using this and stoking false fear among
the Latinos to try to flip Congress
again no ideas just more emotional
manipulation we welcome and we treasure
the Hispanic immigrants in this country
who came here the legal way like TIA
from Venezuela who called in to my radio
show today I was born in Venezuela I am
a proud American citizen now but I am
terrified of what is happening my
mothers would have never thought that
Venezuela 30 years later was going to be
a socialist country and then five eight
years after that was going through
defending to a dictatorship because once
they get in they change the constitution
and now they're not even waiting they
want the Supreme Court because they want
to change the constitution and there
goes our country there goes our country
we get a lot of those calls on the radio
legal immigrants enraged now we all know
the negative changes that open borders
and catch and release bring to America
look no further than to California's
rampant homelessness filthy streets
ballooning welfare programs crushing
regulations that's what a Democrat super
majority sanctuary state ends up looking
like the president is standing up for
you he wants us to stop and this morning
he tweeted we spend billions in forcing
other countries borders as our own has
become a joke our laws ignored and our
generation and compassed compassion
exploited he said it as well he said in
addition to stopping all payments these
countries which seem to have almost no
control over their population I must in
the strongest of terms ask Mexico to
stop this onslaught and if they're in a
to do so I will call up the US military
and close our southern border that's
what his tweet said now the Democrats
talk taking the house will ensure that
this caravan of 4,000 eventually becomes
a flow of four million four million plus
before we know it this cannot happen but
as we told you last night if you're
still on the fence about what to do on
November 6 in the midterm election just
think for a moment about who's in line
to chair the important committees when
it comes to these issues like Homeland
Security and the Judiciary Committee's
if the Democrats do take the house
Bennie's Thompson from Mississippi would
take Homeland Security you would think
the most important homeland security
problem facing the nation is a handful
of Central Americans moving through
Mexico that does not make it so better
to distract the American people from the
real issues facing the department and
perhaps from the president's own
problems too oh and meanwhile Jerry
Nadler would oversee judiciary which
includes immigration and border security
and we know he's far more interested in
investigating justice Cavanaugh than
solving our border problem come on
Hispanic Americans are smart enough to
spot a con when they see one so I say
it's time to walk away from the
Democrats cynical game of identity
politics and emotional manipulation and
toward candidates whose policies result
in higher wages and better security for
all Americans and that's the angle